هذا مرة أخرى يبلغ اليونان.
تسليح الجزر على التلال العسكرية
لا تستسلم يا تان
[موسيقى]
بما يتماشى مع الاتفاقيات الدولية
ندعوكم للعمل
[موسيقى]
حقوق تركيا في بحر إيجة
جزر مثل أنا لن أستسلم
دولي في التسلح
المعترف بها في الاتفاقات
باستخدام الصلاحيات عند الضرورة
لن تتراجع
[موسيقى]
نحن هذا العام تدريب هذا الاجتماع المجلس
سوف يتم من أجلي الآن
لا يوجد كيس أوتا
اشترك
لكن
في حديثنا معك
حتى لا نجلب بيننا دول ثالثة
ابق على هذا الجانب
حتى الآن أنا هنا الأسبوع الماضي
أنه قام برحلة إلى أمريكا وكان عضوًا في مجلس الشيوخ
هذا ما يتطلبه الأمر ضد تركيا
bi e f 16s كما يلقي الخطب
يعني لا تعطي لتركيا
عن طريق
يبدو الأمر كما لو أنه يلقن أمريكا بهذه الطريقة.
هل هو متاح